bild fordert und die politik diskutiert
über konsequenzen auch über ein
angemessenes strafmaß in diesen fällen
aber die zuständige ministerin
bundesjustizministerin christine
lambrecht auch von der spd sie hat jetzt
der aufkommenden forderung nach
schärferer bestrafung von
kinderpornografie zurückgewiesen der
pauschale ruf nach einer
strafverschärfung bei kinderpornographie
wie er etwa von cdu chefin annegret
kramp karrenbauer kommt führe nicht
weiter sagte lamprecht lamprecht
forderte und betonte dass bei einem
kindesmissbrauch bis zu 15 jahre haft
drohen
dies sei das höchste strafmaß die das in
unserer rechtsordnung überhaupt möglich
ist sagte sie härtere strafen also nein
von der zuständigen ministerin
rainer becker vorstandsvorsitzender der
deutschen kinderhilfe ganz herzlich
willkommen hierbei gilt ja wenn sie
diese aussagen der
bundesjustizministerin höheren strafen
sind hoch genug wir brauchen keine
verschärfung was führen sie dann das
macht mich einfach nur wütend
also der altkanzler schröder hatte
selber einmal gesagt in einem anderen
zusammenhang ich habe verstanden alle
plötzlich eine andere richtung
lambrecht hat nichts verstanden die
innenministerkonferenz hat sehr gut
beraten jetzt weitere erhöhung gefordert
jetzt haben sich hier sogar die
jugendminister angeschlossen und zwar
einstimmig und die hat immer noch nicht
begriffen wir haben jetzt neue skandale
die ständig entstehen und sie hat immer
irgendwo aus dem zusammenhang heraus
irgendwelche details heraus gegriffen um
im prinzip er die kinder oder die
potenziellen täter zu schützen
irgendwo die konter konsequent zu
verfolgen im grunde gibt es zwei
wesentliche säulen im strafverfahren
wenn man traf hatten verhüten wird
einmal kann man das machen indem
entdeckungsrisiko erhöht wird
achten wir natürlich an grenzen weil
dann mehr polizisten ausgebildet sind
wir möchten mit technik aber natürlich
auch wieder bessere gesetzliche
rahmenbedingungen zusammen recht auch
wieder baut und dann geht es weiter
diese defizite bei der und risiko
kompensieren durch höhere strafandrohung
und dabei geht es aber nicht darum jetzt
durch die höhere strafandrohung hatten
zu verhüten
gleichzeitig müssen dort berücksichtigen
das ist ja auch ein akt der
wertschätzung dass sie die betroffenen
von solchen taten was die opfer auf dem
system wert sind oder jetzt wert sind
und wenn man an dem motto überlegt wenn
so eine opfer dann erwachsen wird und
erfährt dann auf einmal welche
mindeststrafen es gab oder dass man sagt
das war nicht minder schwere tat oder
jemand wird leichtfertig im grunde oder
es wird aufgrund dich leichtfertig so
einer bewährungsstrafe verurteilt da
kann nur noch den kopf schütteln
und hier hat es auch für die richter
wenn frauen hat recht sagt die schöpfung
ihre möglichkeiten nicht aus eine
gewisse bedeutung wenn man zum beispiel
einen straftatbestand im grundtatbestand
um verbrechen macht seien dadurch ein
besonders schwerer rechtsbruch er
speichert auch unbewusst eigentlich eine
mutter zu stellen hat natürlich eher an
höhere strafe rangehen
als jetzt irgendwo an in dem minimal
bereich sich zu bewegen und verdrängt
die komplett und wie gesagt es ist ein
slogan opfern gegenüber versichert hier
macht für mich einfach nur ohrfeige für
all die zehntausende außerdem betroffen
man geht davon aus dass ihr kind in
deutschland und sexueller gewalt
betroffen
ich weiß nicht roland macht auf mich den
eindruck einer geisterfahrerin
vollkommen und und verwirrt hatte und
nicht mehr weiter weißt also brauchen
jetzt einfach konsequenz notwendig ist
eine ministerin die er für die täter da
ist stadt für die opfer einfach nicht
und ich sage ich in aller deutlichkeit
ich habe die konsequenzen zieht und das
dann eine andere ministerin oder anderen
minister kommt ist für rainer becker
vorsitzender der deutschen kinderhilfe
herr becker welche strafen und welches
strafmaß fordern sie denn also sie
fordern eine erhöhung eine verschärfung
der strafen anders denken sie da es ganz
wesentlich ist dass zum beispiel um
sexuellen missbrauch wobei die sprache
eigentlich auch von magath realisieren
dass diese sexuelle gewalt dass dadurch
grund hat mich dann von vornherein zum
verbrechen gemacht
damit sagt der gesetzgeber das bei uns
ein besonders schwerer rechtsbruch das
ist das wichtigste
bei den frauen recht anführt ist diese
weniger schweren fälle nicht bearbeitet
werden können
dann hält die anfangs recht erfolgreich
und trägt denn die richter haben auch
die möglichkeit dass im gesetzestext
entsprechend formuliert zu sagen
hinter schweren fällen hat das gericht
die möglichkeit nicht strafe zu mindern
aber auch unter ein jahr gehen genauso
wenn zb zwischen dem 1 1 beteiligten
anderen regierung bestanden hat sich
jetzt als beispiel eine 12 jährige die
mit einem 13 jährigen freundes und die
auch sexuell miteinander verkehren
aber nach dem alter aber natürlich
dieser 13/14 werde man jetzt sagen jetzt
ist ein bereich des strafrechts und
hatte kappel stand sexuellen missbrauch
von kindern
weil ja die freunde dann eben noch unter
und wenn man jetzt deutlich macht und
auch das ist eine starke einfach der
formulierung entschieden weil ich eine
beziehung bestanden und bestehen und
jetzt hier hier das auf einleger basis
erfolgt ist was das gericht glück hat
den straffrei zu stellen
solche möglichkeiten gibt es ich weiß
nicht warum das justizministerium so
unfähig ist oder so unmotiviert ist so
etwas dann einfach flexibel zu gestalten
also wir vielen ja schon in einer
pressemitteilung erklärungen ein wo ich
sage ich habe ein paar minuten
nachgedacht und im ministerium hat er
noch einige wochen zeit und lassen sie
uns noch ein bisschen über die fälle
sprechen die ein nur kopfschüttelnd
zurück lassen also fälle wo es heißt das
ganze ist verjährt
müsste man nicht beispielsweise wenn man
die strafen verschärft auch das
abschaffen die verjährung und
bewährungsstrafen wir haben diesem fall
des lehrers er selbst hat zugegeben sich
vergangen zu haben an dem zweijährigen
sohn diesem missbrauch zu haben und
bekommt trotzdem nur bewährung weil er
halt eine therapie macht und so aber die
tat hat er ja de facto begangen und das
ist auch gar nicht in der leugnung also
müsste man bei bewährung bei verjährung
ansetzen aber auch dazugelernt und
ehrlich anfänglich sagt immer muss sich
verjährungsfristen wesentlich nach
hinten verlängern weil ja manchmal auch
die taten gesetzt späten gezeigt wir
hatten dann kann man darüber nachdenken
was bringen für die betroffenen
wenn wir berücksichtigen dass seine tat
verjährt ist
der täter sogar ein recht auf schutz
damit man ihnen dieses nicht mehr
vorwerfen öffentlich und sogar
zivilrechtlich gegen seine ehemalige
opfer vorgehen kann dass sie sozusagen
in einem hofladen
das ist auch schon wieder völlig absurd
und nicht so weit auch noch dies mit
ihren tieren skandal
20 lang hangelt und eine aufregung wird
die nächste bericht an meiner die
verjährungsfrist sollte aufgehoben
werden der die betroffenen haben ganz
klar leben klängen und warum sollten die
täter geschützt werden und gerade
netzwerke lassen sich auch er aufdecken
keine verjährung
ein klarer appell von rainer wendt
vorstandsvorsitzender der deutschen
kinderhilfe rainer becker ganz
herzlichen dank